hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast development a paper-based Zika
virus test I'm Mara Castellanos and lab
routes and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab routes the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge a slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of your slide window if any
technical problems viewing or hearing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green to an A button
lower left this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I'd like to
introduce today's speaker dr. Keith
party dr. party and his assistant
professor and the Lesley Dan faculty
pharmacy at the University of Toronto he
holds honors of Bachelor of Science
degree and biological sciences from the
University of Alberta a Master of
Science degree and the natural products
chemistry from the University of British
Columbia and a Doctor of Philosophy
degree and molecular genetics from the
University of Toronto following his
completion of his doctoral studies dr.
party completed a postdoctoral
fellowship under the supervision of
Professor James J Collins at the least
Institute at Harvard University I'll now
turn it over to dr. party for his
presentation
hi thanks Rob as Rob mentioned I'm at
the University of Toronto and today I
want to talk about how we use our cell 3
synthetic biology applications to
develop zika diagnostics as well as at
the end I'll touch on some new work
we've done in portable drug
manufacturing before I get started I'd
like to knowledge all of the authors on
the Zika virus paper which is a very big
project that we did in a short period of
time
and so there was a lot of people
involved in success in this project the
project was led by James Collins who's
at the Beast Institute at Harvard so
here's just a brief overview of the
topic and start out with some background
on synthetic biology and then I'll get
into how we developed the paper-based
synthetic gene network platform and then
I'll talk about the development of that
platform into a specific Zika virus
diagnostic so synthetic biologists are
aims to sort of rewire reprogrammed
cells with the goal of creating new
sources of green chemistry for the
production of commodities and
therapeutics as well as biofuels and to
do that they are turning microorganisms
into living factories they do this by
placing engineered metabolic pathways
into these organisms that produce the
commodities basically and regulating the
flux through these pathways are often
synthetic team networks and a synthetic
gene network is just simply a
genetically encoded tool there is a
sensor component that can detect small
molecules like metabolites contaminants
environmental cues there's a simple
logic component and a measurable output
and that simple logic component can be
configured into an Gates or gates such a
simple transaction as is the case in the
Zika virus Diagnostics that I'll talk
about where basically if you have an
input you'll get an output and so
fortunate for synthetic biologists
nature is very good at sensing and in
fact life depends upon it finding food
avoiding danger maintaining homeostasis
all require sensors on the molecular
scale and these synthetic biologists are
taken needs embedded them into these
networks so now we have synthetic gene
networks that can detect contaminants
like heavy metals pesticides drugs and
nucleic acid sequences which is the
focus of the Zika talk or the Zika
diagnostic so you can imagine that
synthetic gene networks have a lot of
potential outside of simple bio function
of commodities and we envision these
networks being useful in medicine where
physician could use these networks to
determine the source of an infection in
a patient and to dig deeper to figure
out what other clinically relevant
pieces of information that there such as
antibiotic resistance and the same
paradigm can be applied to food safety
and environmental monitoring the
challenge is that by and large most of
these synthetic gene networks are housed
inside microorganisms like bacteria
yeast and in no way are those compatible
with applications in the hospital the
food industry or released into the
environment and so recognizing the
potential of these synthetic gene
networks what we did was develop an in
vitro system basically a material that's
embedded with these networks and the
material can host these networks and and
they're freeze-dried and stable and
making remain sort of an employee's
state in freeze-dried states that can
just you add water and their state law
and actives but over here
and so I'm going to talk now about how
we develop that foundational platform so
to start basically what we did was we
used this vitro transcription and
translation system which has been used
in the lab as a tool to study
transcription and translation for
decades that works very well and it's
been really instrumental and
understanding and molecular mechanisms
that underpin these processes but for us
to deploy this out of the lab there's
some challenges first of all it's a
liquid reaction and so without pipettes
and other specialized equipment it's
difficult to handle these reactions and
the other is that these reactions are
very labile they require being stored at
minus 80 degrees Celsius and so are
difficult so you bring out of the lab
and so inspired by things like pH paper
and chemistry based Diagnostics such as
that around paper such as those out of
the George Whitesides lab I thought well
perhaps we could merge the two ideas and
so could we put these sulfur systems
synthetic gene networks into paper and
host them now and so on you're right
what you see is paper disks that have
been embedded with these enzymes of
transcription and translation and then
the discs on the braid also received a
DNA plasmid or green fluorescent protein
and while the other disk did not
incubated at 37 degrees and within 20 to
30 minutes you get the expression of
this that's protein so this was a great
start it worked but of course there were
a lot of other components that need to
come together and one of those is the
synthetic gene networks themselves and
I'm especially excited about RNA based
components for this role the state of
the field a few years ago was really
focused on this type of wrapper
regulator and I'll walk you through sort
of how they work on the left side
is red box which so the whole piece of a
piece of DNA the red region codes this
is regression sequence and the blue
region encodes the ragdoll binding site
when transcribed into RNA visas
regression sequence folds over it binds
to the ribosomal binding site blocking
rap sums for binding and therefore
preventing translation in this case of
gfp unless you add another component and
so here the DNA is transcribed you get a
piece of RNA and that RNA has a highers
called the trans activator and has a
higher affinity for that sis regression
sequence then it does for the ribosomal
binding site and as a result the
ribosomal binding site becomes exposed
ribosomes bind and you can get
translation and so this was this is
actually and clearly cool however if you
want to turn these into Diagnostics you
can imagine there's some serious
limitations in basically your trans
activator or the trigger that you're
trying to detect will always have to
have some kind of complementarity the
ribosomal binding segment and so that's
not very useful as a diagnostic and so
my collaborator Alex cream came up with
the bright idea of moving that ribosomal
binding site to the end of a hairpin
and combining it with a molecular seat
she called it toppled and so how this
works is basically the region of that
total switch that hairpin that you see
there that region that's labeled a B is
the sensor surface and because the
ribosome binding site is then there's
very little constraint of what sequences
you can put in there and so the trigger
RNA a-star binds to a which is much like
the tab on a zipper and starts to
unravel the whole and B star binds to be
the result is you get up linearized
piece of RNA double-stranded RNA and the
ribosomal binding site no longer has
that steric strain on it preventing the
ribosome binding and you can get
translation
and because there's few constraints on
what can go into that baby region you
can rationally design these tools and
you can design them to complement
synthetic our names as well as
endogenous mRNAs including those of
pathogens and so this is another early
experiment that we did or basically we
have seven different toehold switches
are seven different pairs of paper all
of the pieces of paper have got the
enzymes of transcription and translation
embedded into them and then freestride
and basically we rehydrate them with
either water loan or water plus the RNA
and you can see that in the presence of
the correct RNA trigger each of those
two little switches turns on to varying
degrees and you can see because these
pieces of paper are 2 millimeters in
diameter they'll fit into a 384-well
plate and you can put these and run
these into in a plate reader and in some
cases very high on ratios and very
digital responses so great but of course
there were more features that were
critical to make this platform field
ready and one was as I've alluded to a
little bit distribution without
refrigeration and so for that we turn to
freeze drying when you freeze dries the
freeze dry these paper-based reactions
they remain active for over a year and
the cost per sensor is about 3 to 68
cents we also wanted to be able to have
colorimetric outputs and so here we want
to be able to in resource environments
we want people to be able to read the
output update their diagnostic in the
absence of power or associated equipment
and so here there's a color based output
that and then finally for more
sophisticated applications we have
electronic and a low-cost electronic
reader that could allow quantification
and automation so how did we create the
color metric output
I tested probably ten different
combinations of proteins and color based
systems and in the end settled back on
laxative oxide days which is a very
common reporter enzyme in biology likely
because it worked so up and it worked
very well and basically pairing it with
CPR G which is the molecule at the
bottom of your screen the enzyme cleaves
along that ether group creates two
separating basically cleaving the
molecule turning the yellow substrate
into a purple clear phenol red molecule
that has the absorbance o nanometers
which is important for the
electronically good and I'll talk looks
shortly but you can see clearly there's
a color change sizable to the eye as
well if we sample those paper discs over
time you can see that the color change
starts around 25 minutes and saturates
around an hour and just taking these
disks the series of disks alone their
images and separate those red green and
blue channels you can see that the
camera on your cell phone could act
served as a companion electronic for
such devices the graphs you see here on
the left side so finally the electronic
reader this was built by Tom Frankie
who's been a great collaborator and he's
sort of our go-to device electronics
imaging guy and he built this device
using a laser cut acrylic housing which
you can see a little low resolution but
I'm but you can still see the box and
that's been constructed and then a green
acrylic chip that has holes in it and
that ship each of those holes contains a
piece of paper that when slid into the
machine sits places those pieces of
paper between an LED but has a very
narrow bandwidth 570 nanometers and an
electronic sensor at the bottom and so
as this purple color is
produced it lots of the transmission and
the sensor detects that change in
relative transmission and and creates
these graphs so at the bottom on the
right you can see the sample data this
is synthetic switch G with various
amounts of trigger and you can see you
would get a dose response curve and the
line thickness response was sort of
corresponds to the standard deviation so
you can see there's not a lot of
variation which is very nice our first
reader cost under hundred dollars and
the readers were using now which have
capacities for much more more many more
samples or under two hundred fifty
dollars and have the PMI on batteries so
that they can be deployed in remote
regions where there's no electricity and
onboard data storage that makes it very
easy to analyze the data afterwards so
to summarize this part of the talk which
is the introduction of the base
technology by taking the synthetic gene
networks out of the cell and embedding
them into paper along with these cell
free systems we've created programmable
and responsive materials and hopefully a
new venue for synthetic biology one of
the big bonuses of this approach is that
you have very short design to test
cycles allowing us to prototype rapidly
and that capability was really important
in our work with the Zika virus the
applications that we're focusing on are
sensing or Diagnostics and on-site
demand manufacturing of therapeutics
which I'll talk about so moving on to
the Zika project at the end of 2014 we
published this first work on paper based
@mg networks we built some some sensors
against antibiotic resistant genes and
Ebola virus which is really exciting
because that this hadn't been done
before but practical you know sort of
locations were that we weren't sensitive
enough yet to be clinically balanced and
so during the 2015 we worked hard to
improve the user sort of
interface as well as make these sensors
are sensitive by developing
amplification schemes in front of the
tonal switch and so with the goal of
having a scheme sort of like this where
you have a free stride system in paper
that contains your synthetic gene
Network and is rehydrated by the
diagnostic sample essentially producing
programmable Diagnostics that could be
you know fairly rapidly applied to any
disease just because it's all sequence
based and that the toe holds which is a
rational design and so in early 2016
when the outbreak of Zika virus in
Brazil was first reported Jim Collins
phoned Alex at his new position in
Arizona in the in Toronto and suggested
that this was an opportunity for us to
contribute to this outbreak by using the
toggle switch in the paper-based
Diagnostics to bring molecular
diagnostics into the field which was key
to the Zika virus and basically the Zika
virus for various reasons requires
molecular diagnostics to be to provide
really clear diagnosis and so we
immediately said yes and put projects on
the side and so did a member of other
people and the team assembled rapidly
and we got to work and so the first
thing was to find genome for the Zika
virus and at that time
Alex there was only one available for
the American strain of the Zika virus
now it was founded on the NCBI database
and using his algorithm walked through
the genome finding regions of the genome
that had low secondary RNA structure and
also were single-stranded basically
regions where the towboats which would
have access to the genome to bind then
he then cross-referenced that against
closely related viruses like the dengue
and chikungunya to make sure that there
were we would not get cross reactivity
with those viruses and then against the
human genome to make sure that there was
no
there and then when he's basically the
algorithm had completed that process
there were 24 regions of the genome that
have been targeted and the complement of
each of those regions labeled here a
through L basically was placed into the
total search in that place where that
bold line is so you can see that this is
a very simple way to build sensors and
with a development cost of our DNA costs
about $20 and our manufacturing costs
about under $1 you can see that while
course antibodies are very sensitive and
certainly have a role in many
applications this new approach is very
fast and has low cost of development and
so it has some really compelling
features for rapidly responding to
outbreaks and so just to recap the
development phase basically the
algorithm designs the sensors and then
DNA synthesis produces them this takes
about four days once we receive the DNA
in the lab takes about took about seven
hours to assemble 48 sensors so this was
two different types of children switches
targeting 24 different regions in the
genome and validate them the Selphy
systems took seven hours and then we
give our day a self a day for
manufacturing distribution to start
guide so this is what the first day to
look like from that seven hour
experiment where we assembled those
sensors and then tested them and you can
see I mentioned there's two different
types of toehold switches we call them
in a series in the P series the B Series
provided higher slightly higher output
and if you look at the inset of that
graph also a lower background we took at
the top a series and the top e series
sensors and tested them to a titration
of our name triggers and as you can see
we really couldn't detect much below 30
nano molar which was not it's unexpected
as I mentioned
during the years about 9:15 we'd spent
the time trying to build up tools for
how we could reach clinically relevant
concentrations of detection which for
the Zika virus is six to seven orders of
magnitude lower so in the low femtomolar
range and so work done by Molina fan and
Donna Braff had been incorporating
isothermal application scheme called
NASA into the work as well this is a
primer directed process where primary
target regions those 24 regions in this
Zika genome to create a basically
double-stranded piece let me play
Cassatt where you have a new strand of
DNA matching the RNA sequence that RNA
is then degraded by earning h and
another primer is used to add t7
promoter to this double-stranded piece
and now you have a piece of DNA that
basically serves as a photocopier that
can produce lots of copies of the RNA in
rapidly and this cycle continues and you
get amplification and it's from this
that we use to rehydrate the reaction
and so when we now place this
application scheme in front of the
toggle switch we can very easily detect
down into the lower molar range you can
see here we've used our name in water or
our name in a fraction of humans here
sort of replicates the diagnostic the
ultimate as a diagnostic so we've now
got the development of the sensor itself
an amplification scheme and now we
needed to develop a buildable method of
extracting the RNA in sample prep we
tried a number of different methods and
in the end settled on a very simple one
which was heating the virus sample up to
95 degrees for one or two minutes to
lyse the virus and release the RNA and
that worked really well in 102 minutes
we were able to
basically the tolls which was able to
what we'd amplify but it would be the
sorry we were able to amplify the virus
rapidly and then from the virus or RNA
from the virus and then the RNA so what
I'm describing here we've gone from
synthetic RNAs that's coded for beaches
in the genome and we're trying to build
complexity and slowly build towards the
type of sample that you'd see in a lab
and so our next step which is the graph
on the top left was taking viruses that
were growing in the Gurkhas lab at MIT
so creates the types of the game thingy
as well as a Zika virus and extract the
RNA from those using the heat based
system and tests it on the total fish so
determine how specific are the Zika
diagnostic was compared and was it
basically could it just specifically
detected and so using RNA that came out
of those viruses could heat method at 30
femtomolar you can see that we had great
specificity and strong signal to Zika
test and taking it a step further we had
samples that were generously provided by
the Connors group at UW Madison they're
working on the effects of Zika virus on
physiology and doing so by working
monkeys and so they sent us Freeman
plasma from macaques and that the viral
concentration of Tamala and so following
heat treatment isothermal amplification
we were able to detect the virus with
the portable reader this is all done
over the cortical reader very you know
at under 30 minutes
and so the amplification scheme here was
two hours or two and a half hours and we
give detection very clear distinction
between the positive and the control
sample
and so in the end we've been able to
build produces paper based platform in
the toggle switches to build Diagnostics
that can detect in clinically-relevant
concentrations and detect all global
strains of the virus we can detect with
these sensors they're capable of
detecting the American strain the Asian
strain the African strain of the virus
and importantly also discriminate
between the strands of the virus as you
may know the American strain of the
virus is associated with rare but very
severe neurological symptoms and so it's
important to be able to discriminate
between these strains we're now at a
point where this project took about six
weeks to produce we now have with this
pipeline sort of established we can now
do this for in about a week now and
cell-free system certainly play and key
role in accelerating that prototyping
I'm not going to talk about our ability
to distinguish between the strains of
the virus and this was an idea that was
generated by gilman bear who was a
postdoc also in Jim's lab and is now
remember Cornell and he'll develop a
system based on module CRISPR cast-on
system and what he did was he looked at
24 regions of the Zika virus genome that
were targeted by the toggle switch and
he looked for what are called pam sites
and sites are help align the katadyn
protein on the genome and they're
basically a nucleotide followed by qgs
and what he was looking for was pam site
that was different between the two
strains and so if you look at the bottom
right i'll explain sort of how it works
using isothermal amplification primers
add on synthetic trigger which we call h
and basically get a double stranded
piece of DNA just as we did in the
original now the reaction except this
time there's that double-stranded piece
at the end and yellow that is the
trigger and so in the presence of the
the full Pam site which is the Americans
train here cast nine recognizes it binds
and cuts and you don't get that trigger
region transcribed into RNA so you don't
get the templates which H
but in the case of the actor constraint
or that Pam site has is no is not
present test nine does not bind you get
the trigger H and cut it into the
trigger at the RNA and you do get sensor
H which is it's a synthetic orthogonal
trigger acted and so through this method
we can get single base pair resolution
differences between the strains so just
to recap this system allows us to take
an unknown sample buyer sample we can
detect all the global strains of the
Zika virus while discriminating from
closely related viruses like dengue and
then we can also distinguish between the
American and the unconstraint and in
this case the Pam sequences results in
the American strain having a paper a
yellow color and strain and so just to
recap we have the part of what we
developed using the system part of old
low-cost diagnostic platform for the
Zika virus that can discriminate between
the viral strains using a CRISPR casts
approach we can detect down into the low
femtomolar range of the virus from
monkey plasma which is in a clinically
relevant concentration and we developed
a programmable sensor workflow that
could be used really for any rapid
response to our next steps are to
incorporate low cost micro fluidics for
sample cup and we're working with
partners towards field trials with in
Brazil Ecuador so
that's so far what I've talked about is
folk has focused on Diagnostics but we
could also use the same self read read
read system to produce therapeutics in a
portable way and the therapeutics that
we're gonna be talking about are largely
proteins protein based narratives that
require coal changing distribution and
this work was published in September and
before I talk about it of course I'd
like to acknowledge all the people that
were involved in this project which was
also done very quickly
what's a large you know effort from all
of these people out of Jim's lab again
at the beasts Institute so just sort of
to give you a real overview of what
we're doing here is instead of a
synthetic gene network at the top of
this chart it's just an expression
contract and instead of a paper-based
reaction it's a free stripe pallet you
know - and basically with the right
construct you can produce lots of
different types of therapeutics and I
like I liken this to basically bringing
the ease of 3d printing to the molecular
level so just as 3d printing can result
in a lot of people to produce lots of
different objects that normally would
require high level of specialized skill
this approach allows people to make
molecular tools and therapeutics
literally in their pocket with just
being able to add water to rehydrate
reactions and so we see this as a
potential useful thing to produce
therapeutics especially protein based
therapeutics that usually require
refrigeration for distribution and
storage to regions that are low
resources and remote they could also
provide low cost their Regents for
research labs and clinical labs around
the world and in vaccine programs
sometimes such as the flu virus strain
composition
and this could allow for this
distributed capability of manufacturing
could allow for repositioning vaccines
efforts more rapidly so just to give you
sort of an overview of what we did we
took the self through systems and put
them into pellets freeze-dried them same
thing with the DNA these can be shipped
room temperature and distributed and
then on-site on-demand
manufacturing by simply rehydrating them
and you can produce these research tools
and therapeutics one of the most
compelling areas I think for this
platform is in the production of
vaccines which have a huge public health
benefit but of course because they are
protein based therapeutics in many cases
that's not all require refrigeration and
this creates challenges especially in
press the world where a refrigeration is
not as so we produced four different
vaccines using this firm one for anthrax
one for theory sorry one for botulinum
in two for deuterium and with
injectables one of the concerns would be
that since we're using a bacterial
system for expression is what are the
risks of injection and what are the
endotoxin levels and basically the
threshold for toxoid level toxoid based
vaccines is 200,000 units of endotoxin
per mil and when we purify our dt v
which is the superior vaccine we had
orders of magnitude below that 596 units
per mil so that was fine as well as when
we injected them into the mice the mice
remained healthy and happy did not seem
to have any adverse reaction to these
products we had habitat control mice
which are on the left in the middle we
had mice that were injected with
purified products from cell three
reactions that did not contain DNA and
on the right the purified product
the TT but selfie reactions that contain
the DNA coding for the DT of the
diphtheria by vaccine you can see around
rate 3 induction anti atheria IgG
response which corresponds to the
production of antibodies or vaccination
in the mouse so we're pretty excited
about this being able to produce a
vaccine from in a portable sort of
compatible fashion from freeze-dried
sample another application that we did
is our ability to make antibody fusions
or conjugated antibodies using cell free
system and so how he did that was on the
left side of your screen we had a
library antibody mimics such as darkens
and antibody
single-chain antibodies such as nano
bodies and on the right side of your
slide we had a library of functional
groups so these are things that you
might want to append or attached to your
antibody such as flesh and proteins my
pasta gave other enzymes and toxins the
antibody mimics our anti antibodies had
ace what's called the spy tag and the
functional groups are the proteins and
enzymes had a spy catcher and when these
see each other they form a covalent bond
that essentially creates a single
molecule and so we can express each of
these domains separately and then post
translation or gap post translation they
confused to form a larger complex
molecule and so the scheme worked very
well we produced 12 different antibodies
and three different darkman's
and the antigens switch their specific
are listed on the right side beside the
anti-flag Western which is labeled E and
below that with the Kumasi gel that's
labeled C are the bands that we produced
from that are the output domains so that
this is the fluorescent protein reused
yfp enzymes which include
families to different types of types of
phosphatase and then cellular toxins so
one from Pseudomonas aeruginosa and
another from diphtheria that could be
used as therapeutics to target for
targeted sub problem so when the Nano
body and the in this case this is an
anti flag Western with an antibody force
against CEA 5 which is a colon cancer
and you can see that that's the band at
the bottom of the Western between the 20
and killed open marker and then then you
see as you go up you see a second set of
bands which is a dimer which happens
sometimes and then these variable bands
that have arrows are the diffusion
products and so here you have in Lane
one you've got CA five fused to wife P
and as you go across so the next step
was functional validation and so here
this is block which you can think of
sort of as an analogue to the Western
blood with four different antibodies one
against epitope an epitope from HIV GFP
rotavirus and schizo and then with
antigens spotted in rows each of those
spots were probed with these antibodies
fused to alkaline phosphatase and you
can see that we get light generation
from the outline phosphatase in the
spots on the diagonal as you would
expect so it worked very well we also
wanted to try using this approach to
produce products for fluorescent imaging
and so what you're seeing here on the
left side are two different cell lines
one that's her2 negative 1 that is 4 to
positive or 2 is a breast cancer surface
marker and using our anti heard to
darken
we were able to probe those cells and
then using a commercial anti-flag
antibody with a fluorescent label you
can see we can marketing we could label
these cells fluorescently by combining
these commercial and in-house prettiest
reagents but we could also do the same
thing with the anti her to derp and that
was used to lively and you can see by
the staining here as you go down you see
the Dappy and then the overlay and then
we you know this is being marker for
breast cancer we thought what could we
are expectedly kill these cells using
and fusion it's linked to a toxic
protein so he is the exotoxin from
Pseudomonas and and targeted it using
the anti air to darken and you can see
on the far right of the column graph
that when we died we did that cell free
reaction by one at 500 or 1000 we got
selective killing of those cells and as
a final example c difficile infections
which affect one of their sort of main
clinical problems that they caused that
they secrete a toxin that causes a lot
of those clinical symptoms that are
associated with the infection and using
an anti c difficile antibody that binds
to that toxin we were able to others
have shown but we were able to produce
that same antibody in a cell-free system
that binds the toxin and neutralizes it
and so in cell based assays you can see
that the y axis here you've got cell
rounding and so along the top are where
all the cells surrounding indicates sub
death and as we increase the amount of
the cell free reaction that expressed
this antibody you can see how we reduce
the cell rounding or the basically cell
down down to zero and images along the
bottom or select this so on the left you
the are the cells in culture exposed to
just PBS basically with no toxin in the
middle cells exposed to talk to me
because you stop rounding just
indicative so and then on the right is
the nano body against the toxin plus the
toxin and you can see we don't get the
cell rounding basically you get rescue
of the cells from a toxin so to
summarize this part basically we use the
cell-free system here as a platform for
on sites on demand like much of the
manufacturing of therapeutics and labrie
agents and has the potential to provide
distribution distributed production of
therapeutics that can overcome
challenges that protein based reagents
therapeutics need which is refrigeration
and although i didn't talk about it
we also demonstrated in addition to
vaccines and conjugate antibodies we
demonstrated the cell-free platform with
antimicrobial peptides as well as small
molecules so to sort of summarize the
whole the whole talk by basically taking
synthetic biology out of the cell and
putting it into materials like paper in
conjunction with the cel-3 reactions
we've been able to create cell 3
Diagnostics based on there are two
networks and a portable block their
manufacturing so in closing are there a
lot of people to thank
i'm grateful for all of their
contributions without which we would
these projects would not have happened
I'm especially thankful to Joe Collins
who was my post doctoral supervisor
through these projects as well as both
of these projects and so with that I
would you know be happy to answer any
questions you know pass it back to rob
or answer your questions
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question-and-answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them and the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window and we're gonna
try to answer as many questions as we
can this time allows so doctor my first
question is can you explain the freeze
drying process that you use for the
paper-based diagnostics and
manufacturing protocols then how do they
differ sure so um so basically we use
sorry I think you're the technical there
we go
so the free shrink process is very
standard it's the same process that is
used by any other freeze drying process
for proteins so it's there's nothing
special about it what differs between
the two is basically in one case for the
Diagnostics for a freeze drying onto
paper and the other case for freeze
drying in a tube to create freeze-dried
pellet and free sharing is basically
done by flash freezing the South Korea
reaction with its associated DNA
contracts in liquid nitrogen and then
placing it on the laughs laser and in a
matter of hours you your samples
freeze-dried Thank You vana next
question is ongoing mutation of the Zika
virus
an issue for the secret diagnostic
great a great question
as you know viruses and pathogens mutate
over time this it's part of their
strategy to avoid the immune response of
their hosts and so the virus does mutate
over time
fortunately the toilets which is very
tolerant communication and can tolerate
as many and that sort of 30 base pair
window that the total switch probes in
tolerate as many as four different
mutations and so with this in mind the
told switches that we build
theoretically have the capacity to
detect all of the Zika virus strains
that have been identified since the
virus was originally identified in 2002
sort of 1947 in in Africa Uganda and so
and we demonstrated that our switches
kids attacks the Asian African and
Americans change the virus and so while
mutation is ongoing and expected to
continue the total switches are expected
to also be very tolerant great thank you
and it looks like we have time for one
last question what are some of the
challenges faced in developing the
manufacturing platform okay yeah so the
challenges between the two platforms
were quite different for the Diagnostics
we were running to hold switches that
essentially we're you know very minor
changes in the sequence but essentially
the same and so once we topped ax my's
the system for one in many ways to be to
optimize the system for all of them in
the case of the therapeutics every
protein is very different and and each
protein or product that we produced
enzyme required
basically optimization to get maximum
expression and maximum activity and so
it does add time to the production but
then once you're done which takes you
know a few days where some cases more
but in theory it can be quite quick your
system is very stable and you just had
to define those character features thank
you and you have any funny closing
remarks for today's event before we let
you go um well thank you so much for the
opportunity to share my work today and
for anyone who's interested please
contact me by email our lab is growing
and and we're very interested in in
bringing having new students join us or
postdocs in the lab as we take both
these platforms these cell-free
technologies towards to expand them out
in manufacturing diagnostic space as
well as develop new technologies
well thank you again doctor party for
your time for your wonderful
presentation I also like to thank lab
birds for making today's educational
webcast possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
February 2017 you'll receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's event until next time goodbye